reteller is dipon gauche
and when i asked what he would stockpile
he said
pop secret home style microwave popcorn
please welcome
dupont hi
so my story starts near the end of my
time as a graduate student at yale
when i started a project exploring
whether this microscopic roundworm
called c
elegans could sense the color of
pigmented bacteria in its environment
now c elegans have neither eyes nor the
genes and proteins animals usually used
to see light let alone color
so these worms being able to sense
colors in their environment would be
like in a word unexpected and
plus it would be pretty difficult to
prove which is something i didn't fully
appreciate at the time
so for reference a reviewer of my
manuscript asked
did the authorist intend to study color
perception in the worm
the results of this manuscript are so
fascinating that one really wants to
hear some of the backstory of how the
authors found themselves in its pursuit
or in non-reviewer speak what did i just
read right so i started this project for
two main reasons
the first was pure unbridled curiosity
i had this idea and i just had to try it
out
the second is i wanted to do a project
all by myself
just to prove to myself that i could and
this second reason really crystallized
one day when i was at my bench observing
worms wiggling around on bacteria of
different colors
as one does when my advisor walked in
was like hey what are you up to which i
responded i won't tell you
in retrospect of course i was
unreasonably aggressive
but to my advisor's credit he just said
okay and he and he walked away and i
thought that was awesome because it
confirmed that i would be working
on my own but i guess i hadn't realized
just how alone i really was there are
zero papers
on this specific topic so i had no
guidebook
for how to proceed each experiment i was
designing more or less from scratch
and each result was a mini discovery but
what were the results telling me
did worms really behave differently with
respect to colorful bacteria
i was really struggling to conceptually
connect all these dots
and this was going on for nine months or
so until one day i announced to the lab
that we should go to a bar to hang out
i don't even drink but i figured that a
bar would be a great place to air my
grievances
about just how much my project sucked
not surprisingly complaining a hydrazium
didn't solve
any of my problems i was so frustrated
and out of just pure desperation i
decided
i had to solve everything right then
right there
so i'm back in my apartment this is like
11 or 12 at night now
and i pull up my white board which is a
must-have accessory for nerds
and i just start brainstorming when
suddenly it hits me
this whole time i've been thinking about
the worms exist in like a grayscale or a
black and white
world if you imagine a black and white
movie
there are no colors per se but you can
tell that something is a different color
because it appears brighter or darker
than something else
and so i was thinking that the worms
could sense colorful bacteria
if that bacteria made the worms world
darker
than wherever the world just came from
but taking a step back
my results were suggesting something
even crazier
worms weren't inferring color just
because their world was getting darker
but rather i think they were able to
discriminate between like
blue and orange so i was
so excited with that i couldn't even
really sleep that night because for the
first time
i had a coherent hypothesis and more
importantly
that hypothesis was testable which is by
far
my favorite kind of hypothesis so the
next morning i rushed to the art store
across the street from my apartment as
soon as it opened and i found exactly
what i was looking for
for ten dollars i bought a filter that
would change the color of the light
i'm back in lab i set up my experiments
with one set of plates illuminated
without the filter and another set of
plates illuminated
through this color filter i just bought
and the bacteria
are the same in both conditions and i
put worms on the bacteria
i give the worms one hour of privacy to
do their thing
and this whole time i'm super nervous
but i'm also so excited and then my
timer goes off
meaning one hour has elapsed and i go to
check on the plate
first i check on the worms on the worms
on the plates
that were illuminated with no filter
okay and on these plates the worms were
just hanging out
on the bacteria so cool all right
then i check on the plates where that
were illuminated using this color filter
and immediately i see that on these
plates the worms had actually
wandered off the bacteria i was blown
away by this discovery
again worms don't have eyes they don't
have the
usual ways in which animals see light
and yet here we are
based on their behavior it is clear that
these worms were somehow sensitive to
the color of light in their environment
that discovery was not only cool it was
also the breakthrough i
needed and that motivated me to keep
going so
fast forward four and a half years
because that's how science works
since that night and i'm still trying to
figure out how the worms sense colors
to the reviewer who asked did the
authors intend to study color perception
i can definitively say that yes i did
why because i just really thought they
might and i had to figure out if that
was right
this is one of the most uh mit-esque
stories i can imagine thank you so much
to pod i love that
we're talking about microscopic worms
and a 10 filter from the art shop over
the road
like that that really like was one of
the reasons i love
working for mit thank you so much japan
welcome our